make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up again
with tales from the dark multiverse this
time we're focusing on
flashpoint so a little bit of an
explanation here for people who are not
familiar with the flashpoint story right
flashpoint is probably one of the most
important stories that dc's done in a
long long time
because that's the story that kicked off
the new 52. so the way this initially
played out to kind of give a really
quick rundown explanation and i believe
that we did cover flashpoint on the
channel so it should be down in the
description
if we did but the idea here is that at
some point along the line
barry allen decided to go back into the
past and save his mom from dying at the
hands of eobard thon and the the idea of
barry is that if he did that then
basically everything would happen the
same way that it always did except now
he'd have his mom in his life the exact
opposite happened that with barry
allen's moms
basically surviving that what it led to
was the flashpoint universe it had this
great big huge series of effects on the
timeline
so that when joe chill went to go murder
thomas and martha lane in crime alley he
actually shot bruce wayne instead
and thomas wayne became batman and
martha wayne became the joker that you
ended up having a war that broke out
between the atlanteans and the uh and
the amazons and that
that's kind of been going on ever since
superman was taken by the government
right as soon as he landed on earth he
was taken by the government so he's
never seen
any kind of civilization there's no
superman lois lane there's
there's none of that stuff right it's
just a really really twisted and dark
universe now the way this worked out was
that barry allen's powers were initially
lost to him and then ultimately he
gained them back
and then basically went back in time and
uh allowed his mom to die and that kind
of
reset the timeline so to speak but it
led into the creation of the new 52
right it was basically dc rebooting and
so what this does is this picks up in
that moment
when barry allen and thomas wayne were
jump starting barry allen's powers right
when they were basically getting his
powers back in
back into play so he could basically
kind of figure out what's going on you
know face off against eobard thong when
he made his presence known and then of
course
go back in time and and let his mom die
the difference here is that when that
happens that eobard thawne
actually seems to strike that when barry
allen does this that eobard thon is just
kind of running through the time stream
but as barry allen's powers come back to
him this kind of quote unquote lightning
strike right the speed force basically
ends up throwing eobard thon
into the flashpoint universe and when he
arrives here he immediately kills barry
allen
right just like that barry allen's gone
and so eobard thawne is the only
speedster in this universe and what's
kind of crazy about this is he looks at
barry and he says man like this is kind
of wild but
but fate seems to have more or less
stepped in with regards to eobard thon
arriving here
barry allen being killed and at that
point eobard thon is kind of like okay
well if my existence was always tied
into the idea of like being better than
you defeating you
you know not necessarily killing you but
i guess ultimately doing it one day and
now barry allen's dead
eobard thawne is kind of free right he's
kind of like okay so
i can just kind of do my thing in this
place now thomas wayne immediately
attacks him right thomas wayne
immediately goes after him and then
eobard thawne goes after thomas wayne
but as he does he begins to pick up on
the memories and the the thoughts and
the feelings of bruce
i'm sorry of thomas wayne and realizes
he's not in the main dc universe from
eobard thawne's perspective this is just
the main dc universe right mary allen's
dead and it's like wow cool awesome but
now that he learns it's an alternate
reality where bruce wayne died instead
of thomas and martha that things are
totally different here that things are
darkly awry and that's when he says like
this world is a gift
there's no real hope here right like
things are pretty bad things are pretty
gloomy and i can build on that right i
can take this world and make it my own
there's no unified justice league the
superheroes who are here
are scattered and divided they're
warring against one another there's no
one to really
challenge me in this place and so with
that being the case we basically jump
over to washington dc with the president
of the united states right and the
president being here
is is kind of interesting because
iamar's thorn basically took off right
we don't really know where he went to
but the president being here is this
guy's basically just kind of a coward
that he's basically scared he's scared
to death of the idea that the amazons
and the atlanteans are going to go to
war they're going to or at least they
have been at war
that one of them will eventually conquer
the united states right because the u.s
doesn't really have the ability to stand
against that kind of power but then in
the middle of all of this right when
when the president is like we don't have
anybody
they can stand against that kind of
power eobard thon smashes the doors open
right just goes ripping through
and just starts taking out everybody
right like like everybody who's here the
green lantern the whole nine yards they
all
fall before eobard thawne because he can
move faster than they can think
at that point there's really not much
they can do and when he sends cyborg
flying out of the place right to see him
flying out of the oval office that's
when he tells the president
i created you you're here because of me
and we end up finding out that the way
this was supposed to play out the reason
why the president here is different than
he was
in the original flashpoint story is
because eobard thawne went into the past
and then basically set things up so this
guy would become president of the united
states right
initially he was a soap opera actor this
guy had no business ever becoming
president of the united states but he
did right eobard thon kind of made it
happen and the reason why is because
this guy's cowardice is such to where
he'll do anything to make sure
everything's okay right i mean this guy
is terrified of confrontation that kind
of stuff
now cyborg does jump back in but he's
atomized by by eobard thon almost
immediately
but the reason why he comes to me is he
basically says like you're you're a weak
man but you are a weak man who is put
into a wildly powerful position
you will basically do anything i tell
you to and if i tell you
that i can end the war between the the
amazons and the atlanteans like
if i can end that conflict and keep
america shore safe then in turn i want
the united states i want to i want to
own america you can keep running it
right that's fine just do whatever you
want with it but i want to be the one
that basically owns it right when i come
into the oval office and i tell you that
i want something done
that thing gets done right like that's
that's what he's shooting for now while
all that's happening because of the fact
that the president basically allies
himself with eobard thawne and says you
know this guy calls himself the flash
that he's got the power that this power
that he has will basically save us the
united states more or less rallies under
him
not a lot of people question him and the
reason why is that in times of
desperation
people will believe what they want to
believe logic and reason they both go
out the window right people just
believe what makes them feel happy well
it makes them feel more comfortable now
that's bad
that's a terrible terrible philosophy to
have but it's just how human beings are
right it's how we as people are
the the important thing is that while
thomas is watching all that one thing to
understand
barry allen's not gonna come back right
barry allen's dead there's no
resurrection for him
in any real former fashion but batman
gets a message from victor stone who
backed up his brain
basically revealing to him the superman
project now the superman project as we
talked about kind of a little bit ago
was the idea that when superman landed
on earth he was taken by the federal
government and then tested
examined all that kind of stuff but
never became the superman that
that we know like the guy who basically
leads superheroes into a better tomorrow
right he
unites superheroes all under this idea
that they can become better people that
superman does not exist
right no one's ever heard of him before
no one knows he exists right there it's
just
one of these things we're just nobody is
aware that it's there now the funny
thing about that this is one of the
things that i love the most about eobard
thon is when you transition back to him
and he's talking to the president and
then eventually transitions and talks to
thomas wayne that he kind of gives us
this really really cool
breakdown of his perception of barry
allen how it is that he truly sees barry
out
because for more often than not whenever
we see eobard thawne discussing the
nature of barry
it's usually done with regards to his
desire to take barry allen down but
because the fact that barry allen's now
dead
then it's kind of how eobard thon really
views him and it's not really anything
honorable like you know barry allen was
like the greatest man i ever met and sex
that he died it's not really anything
like that instead he considers barry
allen to be a selfish person right a
very island to kind of be
no measure of a superhero at all and he
actually is
not wrong here right he's he's really
not wrong and that's what's so
uh so interesting because he kind of
breaks it down he says for all the
superhero antics that barry allen
engaged in
at the end of the day he ran back in
time and saved his mom's life he's like
i
is the reverse flash understand that
time is a nuanced thing it's almost like
threading a needle right you can't just
go lumbering in there like a bowl in a
china shop and just start doing what it
is that you want to do
because it's going to have effects on
time you have to understand how time
works before you manipulate barry allen
did not know and did not care in all
reality that barry allen cared nothing
about the nuance of time
barry allen decided that one day he's
going to save his mom's life and so he
just
ran back through time and he saved his
mom's life with no thought to the
consequences of the actions that he was
engaging in not just in so far as how it
would affect his life but how it would
affect everybody else's life around him
and what it led to
was this terrible horrible world that
you guys live in right now barry allen
created that and it's one of these
things where batman kind of challenges
him a little bit and says you know okay
well then here's my question
from what you're telling me here your
entire existence was based around the
the
notion of barry allen living so what's
the purpose of your existence now right
what's the purpose behind your life why
do you even exist anymore and it's
almost kind of like eobard thorns thrown
into this existential crisis and instead
of answering the question
he deflects he's like what about you
thomas wayne look at you you know like
all you're doing now is you're not a
hero right you're not trying
to save the world or even your city
you're just a man obsessed with
destroying criminals
screaming at the world making it pay for
your pain that's all you really are the
funny thing about that
is that's bruce wayne and that's what's
kind of interesting is that bruce and
thomas are very similar in that regard
and the the
whole gift behind this is that you kind
of get this this interesting situation
where thomas wayne is like okay so
barry allen told me eobard thawne came
from a time
or at least the the world that barry
allen came from that bruce wayne
survived and myself and
and martha wayne died and like any
father they'd want their children to
survive
before themselves right especially
somebody as young as bruce because he
never got a chance to live a life
and so because of that thomas wayne kind
of starts mulling this over when eobard
thawne starts kicking off the idea of
hey
i can go back and i can fix things in
this universe so that your son never
died so that martha never goes insane so
that you never have to become batman you
guys can live the life that you always
imagined you guys living
i can make that happen and when thomas
is kind of like well then will you do it
right well you save them will you bring
my will you bring my boy back the
response of ebar thon
is not a chance right i could but i'm
not going to and i'm not going to
because i don't have to right and then
just leaves there's not a single hope
out there that's not going to happen but
thomas wayne hopes that it could happen
now there are two main things that
happened here
right two main things that come out of
this the first is that looking at the
nature between eobard thought and barry
allen that eobard thon chased allen he
chased barry allen the reason why was
because he had his own motivations right
trying to become better trying to prove
you know whatever it was but he was
obsessed with with barry allen the fact
that barry allen is dead basically left
eobard thon kind of out there trying to
figure himself out and what he does is
he reverts back to what he knows
by presenting thomas wayne with the
possibility that he could save his
family and then choosing not to
thomas wayne will become obsessed with
that idea and he will chase down eobard
thon and so basically eobard thon
now has his own version of quote unquote
eobard thought
a person obsessed with him for the
purpose of trying to achieve a
particular goal the second thing that
comes out of this
is that we're kind of presented with
this idea that hope is not simply just a
concept hope is a tangible thing right
hope is a is a realistic tangible thing
you can't necessarily
touch it but it's palpable right that
the way in which the world functions
right now is because it's a world with
no real hope but as hope begins to grow
in this world from various people due to
various circumstances
the world can actually become a better
place what you end up doing is switching
over to metropolis about 200 meters
below ground
with cyborg who's kind of put his mind
inside of a robot body and thomas wayne
and they're basically traveling to meet
with uh meet with superman right to see
superman for the very first time
and to basically release him the other
part of this is that eobard thawne is
finally maintaining his promise after
about a week to end the war between the
atlanteans and the in the amazons the
first thing he does is he kills aquaman
right he basically says like you know i
had believed that the amazonian queen
would be more reasonable but this is a
gift right you just came
assuming uh presumably running at me
right with all the power and all the
strength that you had and there's just
there's nothing you could really do i've
killed you now i can basically use you
as a means to broker peace
between wonder woman and the atlanteans
and so what he does
is he grabs the body of of aquaman and
then brings it to wonder woman
drops it off in front of her and says
this is a warning you and your old gods
are all finished right you guys are all
done
america is mine if you come here if you
come to the united states i will kill
you all
i will take all of you out this is your
warning there will not be another one
do not come here stay away and it's kind
of nuts because it basically seems to
essentially end the conflict like just
like
that the war is basically done now from
there it switches back over to uh
to thomas wayne and to cyborg and we end
up finding out that with superman being
freed of course because of the fact that
this kind of interesting thing that was
covered here
uh with superman despite not having ever
really met any human beings
the overall gist is that dc kind of ties
into the nature of superman as being a
hopeful person
superman likes to believe in the best of
people and the results of this is that
given the various psychological tests
that were done by a done on him by the
federal government superman desires
friends and so with cyborg and thomas
wayne presuming themselves as friends
then they in turn managed to get him out
right that's why he didn't superman
didn't just immediately attack them
because he was afraid of them or
something like that i'm sure some of you
guys were going to ask that and that's
why i thought it was important to
mention but basically he's just been
sitting here
absorbing solar radiation for like five
days every single minute
out in the daylight and that's it right
like every single minute of daylight for
five days he just hangs there
absorbing all that energy now of course
it's him basically
bolstering his abilities but still right
is superman who's wildly formidable from
there what you end up getting is kind of
like this
this these atlantean ships that are just
sort of sitting out there right now a
plan was formulated between superman and
between cyborg
and uh and thomas wayne but we didn't
really know exactly what that plan was
instead when eobard thaw's attention is
drawn to these atlantean
uh these atlantean ships they're just
kind of sitting out there suddenly he's
attacked by superman and as far as i'm
aware this is the first time we really
get to see a one-on-one fight
between superman and eobard thon what
makes it even more interesting is its
flashpoint superman
versus eobard thon that's what makes
this really really really cool
it's because this is not like the wildly
experienced knows exactly how to handle
eobard thon version of superman they've
never met right now this was eobard thon
facing off against superman in the dc
universe because of the fact that thawne
is a is a
huge enemy like the the main enemy of uh
of barry allen right he's his
arch arch nemesis and because of the
fact that superman has had dealings with
eobard thon in the past he would know
exactly
how to handle the situation but we don't
get that here instead we kind of have
eobard thon who's really sort of
analyzing the nature of superman and
kind of looking at this so we get some
really really cool moments that one he's
not really scared of the idea of
fighting a kryptonian so much as he's
worried about what it means right that
superman embodies hope
more so than that this superman could
take out all the atlanteans and all the
amazons on his own right and he
even goes as far as to say wonder woman
and aquaman just don't come close to the
power of superman here the other part of
that is that superman can hit him from
any direction unlike barry allen who is
like a
a bishop on a chessboard right or a rook
he's not confined to moving
in one singular direction right it's not
like diagonal or
or side to side you know horizontal or
or vertical
only he's like a queen piece he can move
in any direction and so fighting
superman means fighting in a
three-dimensional space because he can
come from any direction top to bottom
left to right and any variation in
between and so because of that eobard
thawne is constantly on his guard but
then goes as far as to say if superman
lands one
punch on eobard hawn that'll be enough
to take him out fast and so because of
that it's really just
bobbing and weaving it's dodging as best
he can he does pick up on these small
little moments for example when superman
uses heat vision that is high frequency
high frequency photons shooting at light
speed but the superman can't really aim
and it's kind of an interesting concept
because it really begs the question when
superman fires off heat vision can he
accurately aim which is to say that if
he sees you in point a
and then you move to point b can he
successfully track you and the
assumption's always been yes because
this is always kind of how we've seen it
play out but when you give it some
thought
the question is can he really can he see
through his heat vision to follow you
right is that really how that works i
don't know
but i feel like it'd be it makes
superman a lot more interesting if he
couldn't
right if he was really just guessing but
it is a cool concept and so i'm curious
post down in the comments section what
you guys think right
should superman legitimately be able to
track somebody while he's using his heat
vision or should the heat vision obscure
his ability to see
and keep him from being able to track
somebody with his eyesight let me know
what you guys think down there but uh
nonetheless
the plan here was not so much for
superman to kill eobard fun that was not
the plan
the plan was for superman to move eobard
thon to a particular location and the
reason for that is because what batman
and what uh what cyborg have done is
they basically set up sonics and the
idea is to effectively
defeat uh defeat eobard thawne by using
ultrasonics that's basically what it is
right to literally use sound
to kind of encase him and to control him
and to sort of keep him locked off now
the other part of that is that batman
goes to pull a gun right and goes to
fire a shot but the response to cyborg
is no we made a we made a deal with
superman that we were not going to kill
eobard thought and where batman is
almost incapacitated for a moment he
takes out cyborg and then his whole
stance is eobard thawne
was never my target i want my son and so
he fires off his shot and he basically
says like his whole stance here was to
effectively convince eobard on or get
eobard thorn to know that batman could
kill him right the batman could actually
take him out by orchestrating this plan
that batman could kill eobard thong and
the only way that eobard thon is going
to have to spend his days
not worrying you know not looking over
his shoulder worrying is today the day
the batman takes me out is to give him
the world that he wants to give him a
world where his son exists
where bruce wayne was safe and that's
what's kind of bonkers because what you
end up also getting here
is batman basically revealing that it
was never his intention to actually kill
eobard thon it was his intention to kill
superman and so he grabs a kryptonite
bullet and fires it off kills superman
on the
spot right and then just says like
eobard thon it's time for you to do your
thing right
and like while that's happening you have
the ships of like the amazons and like
like literally like the invisible ships
like amazons and atlanteans that just
come
flooding into this whole location and
you end up finding out that with eobard
thawne doing what he did
by showing up on the doorstep of wonder
woman with the body of aquaman dropping
it off and saying don't come here that
what he actually did
is he united them right he killed the
king of the atlanteans dropped their
body off at wonder woman and by doing
that
the atlanteans now work alongside the
amazonians right
the amazons and so because that they're
a singular unified force
numbering in the millions right and they
go as far as to say like we're going to
conquer the united states and understand
you were right about one thing
the old gods are basically dead so we
made a deal
with new ones essentially wonder woman
and the the combined atlantean amazon
force made a deal
with dark side of the new gods and boom
tubes just start opening
everywhere so essentially parademons
just come
flooding in it's absolutely nuts now
from there we never really get to see
what happens
instead batman tells the eobard thon get
out of here right like
run give me the world that we agreed to
right you agreed that you would give me
my son back
do that right like like do that
understand you're not bound
by barry allen anymore right it's kind
of like this this quick little voice of
reason you're not bound by barry allen
anymore this world can be anything you
want it to be right this world is 100
yours right it's 100 yours like it
doesn't belong to anybody else
and in that moment eobard thon realizes
yes it is his ability to manipulate time
to travel back and forth through time
basically means he can remake this world
in any number of ways
eobard thon effectively becomes god and
that's what's kind of crazy is
the world changes based on what he wants
that he can travel 30 years into the
past
and maybe like save the life of bruce
wayne then he can travel 30 years into
the past again and maybe only martha
wayne dies and bruce and thomas survive
then he travels into 30 years in the
past again and then maybe it's just like
bruce and thomas who died and martha
wayne survives right does she become
that woman take that concept and just
extrapolate it across the board right
any actor he's ever seen that's
entertaining
can become president of the united
states maybe he makes himself president
for a little while maybe he kind of
messes things up
and just sees what it's like when like
wonder woman and dark side fight to the
death on earth and just
engineers things to happen that way
there's no limit to the possibilities of
what eobard thawne can make out of the
earth and that's why we don't get a
definitive ending to what this earth
will look like when eobard thon runs
through time because the possibilities
of what the earth can look like have no
limits right
there's no telling what could happen and
and pretty much as we're told here any
and all those possibilities
will come to fruition they will actually
take place but regardless
the world now belongs to eobard thon
this dark multiverse world belongs
completely and totally to him now what's
really interesting here is that there is
basically a dark multiverse eobard thon
now so what i'm curious to see is how
they're going to change that character
what they're going to do with him but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and i will catch you all
later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you